εναι τούτον το ερώτημα μως διότι τού τον δημοκρατί θεωρείσει ότι κάποιτο ερώότημα ένει να
μη γίνονται ενέργειες για να φτάσουμε ην στην προφιτία καιαιδεν δεν θεωρώ θελωνά το ξεκαθαρίσομ
να μελεχθει κάτι να μην ει κάτιλάθος διότι θεωρώ ότι γίνονται τέτοιας ενέργειεςι δουλάχιστο ε
δενμε τις άποψεης ότι οι όποιες ενέργειες μπρεί να γίνονται έχουν επίδραση εγώ βλέπω εγώ
που το δικό μου που το συμβούλειο παρακολοθεί σας πουμε βλεπω πολύ κοσμο να έρκεται
προς τα μέσα νανα μου ζητά να βοηθήσει ν μου ζητά να κάτσει σε επιτρόπες
να μας ζητάνα νν να έρτει να πει την άποψη του το πως πάμε παρακάτω
καιτα λοιπά για τα λιπά έχω την αίσθηση ότι είμαστενούλοιποάπιασμένει επαναλαβάνω που τα πρόσωπο νέρα
γ φίλε σίουρα εμένα το μιχάλι το ανιδιίναι να έχωκωσε αθώς που κάμε αντιπαθού και
μποράμμου γράφούν που προεν και σημαίνει ότι θα ψηφίσω της ναγεμό ν και σημαίνει ότι
ανέχει δέκα άτομα πο ενοχλούαι που ότι παρουσίαν της αννίδας ότι και είναι ανθρώποι δε
θα ψηφσουν συναγερμό όμως κάποιο να βολεύονται να μην πακαλά το πόματωπο έξι για να
θέσουν θέμα για την αννδα τιε ε να α να σας κρίνο ναας κρίνω ακάποιουν
μπορεί να βολεύονται να χάσει ονείν πρόεδρος του συναγερμού βεβαίουν μπορεί το ερώτημαείναι συμπεριφοράτους ετέτοια
νομιζόη αλλάσουμαλλά ανδιοκρίνομ εντικιμενικά σιπάντα ότ του του προέδρούπντα πολεύκονταιπου κάτω αλλά ν και έχει
τέθοια αφαινόμενα τουλάχιστον εγώ δεν α παρατηρώεκεί που υσιέχει φαινόμενο όμως υπάσουν αντιπαθούυν τον μιχάλι
να γράψουν του μιχάλι αντιπαθάνουν α τησέα να να γράψουν το δυσαία α κάμουμε σε
μια σς